tenemos esta reacción en donde ponemos
fósforo sólido con cloro gaseoso y que
resulta de forma espontánea a producir
tri cloruro de fósforo en forma líquida
inicialmente nos dan 1.45 gramos de este
fósforo molecular que el fósforo
molecular en estado sólido
simplemente son cuatro átomos de fósforo
juntitos y si nos dan esa cantidad
inicial nos preguntan cuántos gramos de
cloro gaseoso es requerido para poder
llevar a cabo esta reacción dados estos
1.45 gramos de fósforo y la otra
pregunta que tenemos es bueno cuánto
three cloruro de fósforo es producido de
esta forma y antes de empezar este
problema de este que o metría que todos
los problemas de este geometría es
esencialmente el nombre rimbombante para
para estos problemas en donde te dicen
bueno tengo una cantidad de cierta
sustancia que reacciona con otra la
pregunta es cuánta cantidad de esta otra
sustancia necesito para llevar a cabo la
reacción o también qué cantidad de
este producto resulta al final de
llevarse a cabo esta esta reacción y
antes de empezar este tipo de problemas
lo que necesitamos es tener o más bien
estar seguros de que la ecuación está
balanceada qué significa esto que el
mismo número de átomos de cada elemento
esté del lado de los reactivos que del
lado de los productos entonces empecemos
por ejemplo con el fósforo en el fósforo
nosotros tenemos del lado izquierdo
cuatro átomos solo para esta molécula
aquí no hay así que del lado derecho
sólo tenemos un átomo es decir está
desbalanceado cómo podemos balancear
esto bueno tomando cuatro moléculas de
aquí si tomamos cuatro moléculas como
cada una tiene un fósforo ya tenemos
equilibrados los fósforos ahora vamos a
ver qué pasa con los claros del lado
izquierdo tengo dos claros mientras que
del lado derecho tengo cuatro moléculas
y cada una tiene tres claros así que
tengo 12 como puedo hacerle para
balancear esto bueno si aquí por ejemplo
tomamos 6 moléculas
cada una tiene dos claros tenemos ya 12
ya tenemos 4 claros del lado izquierdo 4
del lado derecho 6 claros del lado
izquierdo 6 perdón son 12 claros del
lado izquierdo 12 claros del lado
derecho ya con esto tenemos balanceada
la ecuación muy bien ahora que ya la
tenemos de esta forma necesitamos
calcular los moles de fósforo que yo
tengo y esto por qué porque podemos usar
las proporciones este geométricas es
decir si por cada molde fósforo yo
utilizo 6 de cloro y produzco 4 detrick
cloruro de fósforo para esta cantidad de
moles que representan estos gramos la
proporción se va a mantener así entonces
vamos a calcular los moles que tenemos
en estos gramos y para eso usamos
nuestra tabla periódica
está por cierto la obtuve de ciencias
galilei puntocom y bueno aquí ya he
marcado el fósforo el fósforo tiene un
peso de 30.97 30.97 que lo podemos
redondear en 31 vamos a dejarlo
de esa forma el fósforo tiene tiene un
peso atómico peso atómico
de 31 gramos
ahora bien a nosotros nos interesa
realmente quién es el fósforo el peso
del fósforo molecular es decir si el
fósforo molecular son cuatro átomos de
fósforo pues simplemente este numerito
hay que multiplicarlo por cuatro y esos
son 124 gramos que es lo que hemos
obtenido de aquí podemos concluir que un
molde de fósforo equivale a 124 gramos
de fósforo muy bien muy bien entonces lo
que tenemos en realidad son 1.45 gramos
de fósforo ok vamos a dejarlo
simplemente así como un fósforo que son
estos de acá y como esto es como un 1 es
decir un molde fósforo es igual a 124
gramos de fósforo es equivalente
entonces podemos multiplicar por este 1
un mod de fósforo sobre
124 gramos de fósforo muy bien que es lo
que hemos obtenido con esto esto
esencialmente es un problema clásico de
conversión de unidades lo que hemos
conseguido haciendo esto es que los
gramos de fósforo se cancelan y al final
lo que tenemos es 1.45 por 1 sobre 124
pero las unidades restantes son moles de
fósforo y esto quien es bueno vamos a
sacar la calculadora y veamos esto es
1.45 por 1 entre 124 que esencialmente
es dividir entre 124 y esto es 0.01 169
vamos a redondear lo en 0.01 17
entonces aquí vamos a tener 0.01 17
moles de fósforo
muy bien ya que tenemos esta cantidad de
moles de fósforo lo que vamos a hacer es
ver cuántos moles de cloro necesito y
vamos a usar las proporciones este
geométricas
es decir
vamos a tener que
tengo 0.01 17 moles de fósforo
y es que es lo que sabemos que es lo que
sabemos que por cada molde fósforo voy a
ponerlo acá abajo para poder cancelarlo
por cada molde fósforo yo voy a requerir
6 moles 6 moles de cl 2 y vamos a
ponerle aquí en la condición de que sean
requeridos que de hecho aquí también se
lo puedo poner requeridos y esto que nos
da bueno lo que tenemos es que los moles
de fósforo requeridos se cancelan y
simplemente me van a quedar moles de
cloro requeridos y cuánto va a ser esto
pues va a ser 6 por 0.01 17 aquí ya
tenemos el 0 11 7
simplemente multiplicamos por 6 y me da
0.07 0 1 en fin vamos a redondear lo en
0.07
estos van a ser
0.07 moles de cloro gaseoso requeridos
perfecto ahora la pregunta ya sabemos
cuántos moles de cloro tenemos eso es
una gran ganancia la pregunta que nos
hacen es cuántos gramos de cloro son
requeridos así que hay que convertir
estos moles en gramos y vamos a recurrir
recurrir otra vez a la tabla periódica
de hecho aquí ya había marcado el peso
molecular del cloro que son 35 punto 45
gramos
entonces fíjense en lo siguiente tenemos
que del peso del cloro su peso atómico
peso atómico es de 35 puntos 45 pero nos
interesa el cloro gaseoso este el cloro
y atómico con dos átomos entonces
simplemente su peso atómico será el
resultado de multiplicar el resultado
anterior por 2 que esencialmente son que
serán como 70.9 en no no no quiero
equivocarme así que vamos a hacerlo con
la calculadora tengo 35.45 por dos eran
70.9 si no necesitaba de la calculadora
son gramos todos estos entonces tengo
70.9 gramos
muy bien entonces qué es lo que tenemos
nuevamente vamos a tener cero puntos
0.07 moles de cloro requeridos
requeridos que podemos multiplicar
déjenme ponerle su color por si ponemos
moles de aire aquí abajo entonces tengo
un molde de cl 2 requerido en realidad
equivale a 70.9 gramos 70.9 gramos de cl
2 requerido y esto cuánto es
esto va a ser simplemente los moles de
cl 2 se cancelan se cancelan y
simplemente me queda 0.07 x 70.9 gramos
de cl 2 vamos a ver cuánto es esto aquí
tenemos los 70.9 simplemente
multiplicamos por 0 punto
07 y esto es 4.96 3 vamos a dejarlo en
4.96 entonces tenemos 4.96 gramos de cl
2 requerido
gramos de cl 2 requerido y ya tenemos la
primer respuesta la primera respuesta
aquí es 4 punto que dije
96 gramos 4.96 gramos muy bien entonces
a ver hagamos una recapitulación rápida
tenían que porque tenía esta ecuación la
cual balanceamos para poder utilizar
las proporciones hasta que o métricas la
balanceamos y pasamos la cantidad de
cloro de gramos perdón de fósforo a
moles esa cantidad de moles las
proporciones se conservan así que
obtuvimos de esta forma con un cambio de
unidades los moles de cl 2 requeridos y
finalmente eso lo convertimos a gramos
ok
todo esto usando también la la la tabla
periódica ahora tengo un detalle extra
me preguntan cuánto tri cloruro de
fósforo es producido así que vamos a
tenemos dos formas de resolver este
problema
es fácil la otra difícil la forma
difícil es hacer lo mismo es decir por
cada molde fósforo yo produzco 4
entonces obtengo la cantidad de moles
correspondientes a este a esta cantidad
de gramos que son 0.01 17 moles de
fósforo obtengo la cantidad de moles de
fort detrick cloruro de fósforo que
produzco y luego lo convierto a gramos
esa es la forma difícil pero yo voy a
hacer la forma fácil y es utilizando la
idea de que la masa se conserva es decir
la misma cantidad de reactivo del peso
de los reactivos que yo tenga el lado
izquierdo será la misma cantidad que yo
debo tener del lado derecho entonces si
aquí yo tengo 1.45 gramos y cuántos
gramos obtuve son 4.96 gramos requeridos
de cloro de cloro gaseoso entonces esta
cantidad debe ser exactamente la misma
que la del lado derecho y simplemente
tengo que sumar
vamos a ver tengo 1
punto 45 45 + 4.96 y eso nos da 6.41
gramos de three cloruro de fósforo eso
son cuatro puntos 96 gramos de three
cloruro de fósforo y ya hemos terminado